se llaman a sí mismos Guerreros de la
primera línea un grupo de hombres que
trabajan día y noche para reforzar esta
barricada construida apresuradamente con
sacos de arena y barro la única Barrera
que protege la ciudad de mejar de las
aguas que se elevan a su alrededor se
extiende de 25 a 30 kilómetros el agua
ha arrasado con las tierras de cultivo
de los alrededores y con cientos de
pueblos donde la gente sigue varada
escuchamos que los cuerpos están tirados
en los techos y no hay ningún esfuerzo
de rescate los oficiales del ejército
vienen y tratan de rescatar a las
personas pero los operadores de botes
privados cobran tarifas elevadas los que
se ahogan en la inundación son gente
pobre que no tiene dinero
muchos de los evacuados ahora viven en
campamentos como este esta mujer ayesha
logró salir Justo a tiempo para dar a
luz a su bebé en un hospital cercano
a veces no tenemos comida durante dos
días no estoy produciendo leche para
amamantar a mi hijo estoy enferma y mi
hijo también está enfermo en una visita
de dos días a la zona el secretario
general de la ONU la llamó una
carnicería climática como nunca antes
había visto con un área inundada tres
veces el tamaño de su país de origen
Portugal
el cambio climático causado por la
actividad humana está sobrecargando las
tormentas y las catástrofes en Pakistán
pero también en chat en el cuerno de
África con una terrible sequía y el
riesgo de hambruna y más allá todos
estos países no causaron el problema
pero están pagando el precio
Antonio Gutiérrez se pidió ayuda
económica masiva y urgente diciendo que
no es solo una cuestión de generosidad
sino de Justicia según la ONU un tercio
de Pakistán y estaba bajo agua más de
1.300 personas han muerto y decenas de
millones ahora están sin hogar